I just want to bring you some breaking
news regarding our top story and the BBC
uh new claims have emerged about the BBC
presenter the unnamed BBC presenter he
is facing new claims about a second
young person uh this is what we know
this has come from the BBC within
literally the last few seconds a young
person has told BBC news they felt
threatened by the BBC presenter who is
at the center of a row over payments for
sexually explicit photos the individual
in their early 20s was first contacted
anonymously by the male presenter on a
dating app they say they were put under
pressure to meet up but never did when
the young person hinted online they
might name the presenter they were sent
abusive expletive filled messages or
speaking to BBC News the young person
who has no connection to the person at
the center of the sun's story about
payments for photos said they had been
shared by the power the presenter had
they said the threats made in the
messages had frightened them and they
remain scared the new allegations of
menacing and bullying Behavior by the
high profile presenter race fresh
questions about his conduct BBC News has
contacted the presenter directly and Via
his lawyer but has received no response
to these latest allegations so that is
the breaking news this afternoon here on
Sky News uh fresh claims from a second
young person involving the unnamed male
BBC presenter just to run you through
this latest statement again and the
information we're getting from the BBC
is this person is not known to the young
person involved in the original claims
uh made to the BBC and the Sun newspaper
this is entirely a separate set of
allegations and the two complainants are
not known to each other
um we are hearing a little bit more now
actually
um
okay more on those fresh claims after
the young person the presenter had first
connected on the dating app the
conversation moved to other platforms at
this stage the presenter revealed his
identity and told the young person not
to tell anyone later the young person
alluded online to having contact with a
BBC presenter and implied they would
name him at some point the presenter
reacted by sending a number of
threatening messages Which BBC News has
seen so let's just run you through what
we know at this point a young person has
told BBC news that they felt threatened
by the BBC presenter at the center of
arau over payment for sexually explicit
photos
the individual in their early 20s was
first contacted anonymously by the male
presenter on a dating app they said they
were put under pressure to meet up but
never did when the young person hinted
online they might name the presenter
they were sent abusive expletive filled
messages
speaking to BBC News the young person
who has no connection to the person at
the center of the sun's story about
payment for photos said they had been
scared by the power the presenter held
they said the threats made in the
messages had frightened them and they
remain scared the new allegations of
menacing and bullying Behavior by the
high profile presenter raised fresh
questions about his conduct BBC News has
contacted the presenter directly and Via
his lawyers but has received no response
to the latest allegations